guys we watched the Oscars last night
and that means it's time for the 2014
grouchy's we're still calling it that
okay then last year you called us out
for being a little bit too mean so I
went online asked the Twitterverse how
mean should we be you said be ruthless
so if you want to see someone falling
all over Kate Blanchet go watch Good
Morning America if you want the straight
scoop stick around
first up the Ellen degenerate award for
bullying Oscar attendees the nominees
are calling out Amy Adams for not
attending college Amy Adams he went to
college right no okay well that would
appear informing the audience that
Jennifer Lawrence fell down last year
and this year on the red carpet she fell
on the way out of the car like on our
orange cone you tripped or something and
the winner is calling Liza Minnelli a
man good job sir I mean that is really
cut the woman a break she was on
Arrested Development
next up Oh a big award comes early this
is the twinkling Tatas award and the
winner is and half the way for wearing a
chandelier on her chest I dreamed a
dream that I could look at you without
sunglasses this next award is very
important the let's not let John
Travolta pronounce anything award you
may remember this moment from last year
John Travolta's pronunciation of leymah
Saurabh name is Oh happiness mr.
Travolta and his hairline were added
again he had the simple job of
introducing idina menzel
and here's what happened please welcome
the wickedly talented one and only a
dead does he Congrats John Travolta you
don't know how to pronounce things and
you have a big face now it's time for
the I don't want to be here award the
nominees are Amy Adams for sexting Henry
Cavill Sidney Poitier for knowing that
he's more important than anyone in that
room and the winner is Harrison Ford
it's a euphoric mix of comedy and crime
it's a poignant transcendent journey
riveting and raucous it's a wild
exhilarating ride everybody fasten your
seat belts that speech was an
exhilarating thrill ride mr. Ford now
it's time for the BuzzFeed gif of the
night the winner is Joseph
gordon-levitt's jazzy fingers at the
time of taping it wasn't up on BuzzFeed
but we're sure it will be in the morning
and now the nominees for Best human
moment Lupita Nyong'o speech Bette
Midler's in memoriam performance and the
winner is Bill Murray's Harold Ramis
shoutout
oh we forgot one Harold Ramis for
Caddyshack Ghostbusters and ground huh
see on the other side he gone the
awkward transition award goes to Morgan
Neville for this gym I first want to
thank along with my producer Kate our
other producer Gil Teresa I remember you
said I want to win an Oscar
I remember thinking you're crazy that
will never happen
Gil passed away well I guess you won
that bet Morgan because he'll never know
he's dead as you so gracefully pointed
out guys let's take a break from the
awards here was a mini rant on this
year's Oscars our good friend Nick Mundy
all right it's late let's just get this
over with okay this is how to fix the
Oscars step one and that was all these
goddamn montages the first one was like
about animation and then the third one I
sold no idea - the third one was about
it was just like movies it was just
clips from movies - the Man of Steel
soundtrack it made no sense if you're
gonna do a montage have a point
you're gonna host the Oscars get some
writers okay Ellen thinks she's
just too good for writers she just
improved the whole thing willy-nilly she
probably had writers well she didn't
listen to him what was wrong he was in
six movies this year you couldn't have a
present an award he could have gotten
Best Supporting Actor for fast
Nick Monday everybody this is both the
Oscars are booked don't home and have a
rock Marathon okay next next up the do
we clap award and the winner is Cate
Blanchet thanking Woody Allen thank you
so much woody for costing me
I'm truly appreciate it
congratulations Kate this next award is
a doozy the best selfie award it comes
from a night where a selfie broke
Twitter the winner is Matthew
McConaughey for saying his hero is
himself ten years from now this person
comes up says you hero I said I thought
about it you know who it is I said it's
me in ten years that doesn't sound right
that's not the thing you should say you
rich Hollywood actor you could tell the
audience wasn't into it because you had
to dig deep and bring this gem back
today I say all right all right all
right all right all right we're back on
boy
next up we have an award of gargantuan
importance the thanks for reminding me
that TV is better award the nominees are
Olivia Pope from scandal rusty Cole from
true detective Sherlock Holmes from
Sherlock and the winner is Congressman
Frank Underwood from house of cards and
I sing because it's so nice to be out of
Washington and here with all my
Hollywood friends he spoke as his
character that was a legit cool moment
and here's thee and this is why people
rehearse award it goes to Ellen
DeGeneres for the following moments
stumbling through speeches and I have to
say one of the most amazing Liza
Minnelli impersonators I have ever seen
in my entire life
ladies and gentlemen Christopher
Kristoff sorry Kristoff vaults moments
of silence
[Music]
general not knowing of what is happening
you hold that actually now hold this you
all the food what you got there just
like
doing this Lupita you gonna have some
pizza ah okay and pimping out your own
Twitter handle in the history I'd never
do that well that was a good time what
do you guys think of the show where we
to mean do you have any favorite moments
that frozen bit was cute and tell us who
do you want to see host the show next
year let us know in the comments section
below best answer we'll send you a
screen junkies t-shirt I want to thank
all of you who hung out with us on
Twitter at screen junkies and all the
screen junkies long hours and watch the
show live Nick Gilly Spencer de Laura
Ashland mark Paul Georgie Dan Andy Ian
thanks for being there guys and thank
you guys for watching screen junkies I'm
Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye bye
Jake oh yeah Chico Chico walk we're
triplets trick